recently naval ravicon had a tweet where
he said that bitcoin is the second
amendment which is very in line with
what you're talking about here in terms
of it is the defense mexico is your
right to bear arms right not necessarily
for offensive purposes but also for
defensive purposes and so when you start
to think about this the network itself
when you unpack the players or the
market participants if you will there's
the miners and the node operators how do
you think about the relationship between
those two as part of this defense system
for your purchasing power or your
economic value and also how do you think
about kind of them in relationship to if
there was some attack and doesn't have
to be a nation-state attack could be a
bad actor it could be a whole bunch of
different things but unpack a little bit
more about this idea of like the network
is the defense system really there ends
up being kind of two core players right
in in terms of uh the node operation the
miners how do they fit into this in in
your kind of framework so this is where
the exploration of bitcoin becomes so
fascinating because to really fully
understand what it does and what value
it brings you have to
think very big and so if you this is
if you think about civilization you know
itself the role of governments the role
of
militaries the role of currency
bitcoin has a little bit of everything
right so
you know you can you can abstract
governments
as effectively a trade mediation as a
service
right this is like it gets back to like
the champagne fairs in medieval uh
europe you would need a military you
need a military to preserve trade routes
right that's why we have navy
okay the navy will make sure that we
don't you know that our trade routes are
uninterrupted
you need a rule of law right to preserve
the the rules of the contracts to build
the contracts to preserve the rules of
the contracts and then you need a a a
monetary
entity as well
bitcoin is all three it is a military it
is a rule of law and it is money
the miners the mining network is its
military
the nodes
right and the software is the rule of
law and the legislation and all the
voting
and
the least interesting part of it in my
opinion is
the money this the satoshi's right
uh that's like the thing that comes
last
what what makes bitcoin so special is
that
it has its own
military
that is literally as powerful
as nation-state militaries when you
think of that right so if you think of
that exact idea where it is built in one
of the things that i wrote maybe two
years ago at this point which i took a
ton of flak for at the time was this
idea that uh the money
historically on its rise to let's say
global reserve currency status or high
adoptability
ends up almost always being catapulted
to that position via violent conflict in
which one party ends up being successful
over another and then they establish
their money right so you're one nation
i'm another nation you have the global
reserve currency i show up i conquer you
now my money is the global reserve
currency so there's a violent conflict
that occurs and what i wrote about was
this idea that bitcoin specifically
would be the first currency the first
store value to rise to global reserve
status without ever dropping a bomb
shooting a bullet needing soldiers guns
etc and the idea was in the analog world
the person who has the best offense is
the most powerful so if you have the
most firepower if you're the most
effective from an offensive standpoint
you are the most successful military in
terms of going and conquering but in the
cyber virtual what you know digital
world
if you have the best defense you're
actually the most powerful because all
you have to do is basically continue to
defend
24 7 365 without fail no matter what the
attack is and therefore people
begin to slowly adopt and realize that
this is the strongest thing and so
bitcoin's computing network is the
strongest computer network in the world
and therefore has the greatest defense
and if it has the greatest defense it
will continue to prove to be the
strongest the thing that people can put
the most trust in and over time it just
continues to kind of outlast everything
else and so my thought process was like
the world changes when we go from like
an analog based world to a digital based
world and now it's not about offense
it's about defense which actually seems
to be somewhat in line with what you're
talking about here of the money and the
quote-unquote army being
won right they come together in a
package i can give you my thoughts and
and for the record all of these thoughts
are my thoughts these do not represent
the dod thoughts
[Music]
first of all yeah it is interesting the
correlation
between
the entity with the dominant military
tends to have
the world reserve currency right if you
read that
it's also interesting that if you read
history
history
is effectively a time partitioned ledger
written
by those who projected the most kinetic
power and and won right
his history is written by the victors
history is written by the those who
won the power projection game right the
competition
okay
so
that's interesting the the the
distinction between offense and defense
is one that
especially in the space force is not
very useful
we can um
and i can kind of like we can
i'll illustrate that
if china were to put or let's say china
russia stand were to put a
nuclear-tipped hypersonic missile
into a parking orbit around the moon
is that an offensive action or is that a
defensive action
you're going to be more of an expert
than me i don't know what is it
right so
okay let's ask another question if
the united states
blows up
that nuclear-tipped hypersonic
warhead in
in orbit around the moon is that an
offensive action or is that a defensive
action
uh you hopefully you got the answers man
because i don't
yeah the the answer is
physics doesn't care right like the
answer is
physics is blind to the distinction
between offense and defense
and so
especially in the year 2021 where much
of everything we do is interconnected is
is cyber is space
the distinction between what is an
offensive action and a defensive action
is gradually less meaningful
at the end of the day the first
principal's view of
any military action is
you're projecting
power right you are transferring joules
per second
right and yes
you know like whether or not you
interpret that as an offense and
defensive action is essentially what
side of the trade are you on china
russia stan is going to have a very
different opinion if we blow up their
nuclear warhead in lunar orbit than
america right so
in my like the way i look at it is
i i choose to look at things the way
that physics looks at things and physics
is blind to the distinction between
offense and defense
that being said
it is useful
to consider okay there may be different
types of ways that you can project
power right if you if i you know punch
you in the face what am i doing i am
displacing the mass of your head
over some distance
right which means i've
created energy right i've created joules
right and i've and the transfer of
joules over time is
power but that's not the only way to
create joules i could also
put a charge across a resistor
right and you've
you've created electric energy
and the transfer of electric energy is
still joules per second there is
fundamentally no distinction between
kinetic power projection
and electric
power projection it's just how that
power is generated that's the difference